Speaker 1: Let's go next. All right. I mean, maybe
against my better judgment. I'm curious what he
has to say. Let's go to Jimmy from Philly.
Jimmy, you are on the air. Hey, David, how
are you doing? I'm doing well. Thank you, Jimmy.
Speaker 3: So, David, I just want to say that,
listen, that prosecutor kind of
reminded me of when I talk to you,
Speaker 1: I'm sorry, your witch project.
What are you talking about, Jimi?
Speaker 3: Listening to the prosecutor in the
Kyle case? Oh, really? Yeah, she reminds me
what other Kyle was there gave it. My God,
you've been doing this for eight hours. And
you're good at follow me for
a loop, David. Yeah, like
I. Yeah, listen to that prosecutor
reminds me of speaking to you because
he was trying to trap Kyle into saying different
things, which is the same thing you do with me.
And at the end of the day, when I don't
say you just lie and say that, I said,
Speaker 1: Hmm, I thought you were going to
say that the prosecutor reminded me of me
because of his incredible poise,
preparation and how articulate he was.
Speaker 3: Well, how about when he basically
disregarded the judge's orders many times, which
then pissed off the judge? Yeah. Most of your
chat thinks that he's biased towards Kyle now.
He purposely pissed off the judge, and then you
got a reaction from the judge. I mean, it's very
clear. I mean, he's disregarded the judge's orders
numerous times. You can't do that in a courtroom,
surprising to hold him in contempt..
Speaker 1: Well, Jimi, I really
appreciate your legal insights. What
do you expect in terms of the verdict?
Speaker 3: Oh, I tend to agree with you. I think
that I don't think that he will be found guilty of
murder, but at one gun charge, maybe he maybe
he gets found guilty on that. I'm not sure. Hmm.
You know, I don't think the kid goes to prison.
Clearly, the judge ain't going to hurt him
right now. What's going on at your place?
Speaker 1: It sounds wild. There's chimes and
different elements, but what's happening
at your place? It sounds crazy today.
Speaker 3: I'm. Sure some of these trolli